- Say hi to Kit Hoover,
have y'all met before?
- Hi.
- Hello.
- We have never met but I
loved you on "Succession."
- Oh thank you, thank you.
- Nice to meet you, so where
are you from originally?
We're both Southern.
- I am originally from Arkansas Central.
- [Kelly] Oh you're Southern?
- Yeah, yeah,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Arkansas people?
- [Kelly] Arkansas.
- Yeah, where from?
Where from?
- Jonesboro.
- [Justin] Jonesboro.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Atkins, Arkansas.
And I grew up on a farm
out there in farm country,
one of the few black
farming families out there.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- And did all types of things,
raised cows, chickens, hogs, and--
- [Kelly] You're like a cowboy.
- [Justin] Pretty much, pretty much.
- Okay.
- Rode horses every weekend.
My dad would come in and we
knew that we'd have to go out
and catch cows and take them to the sale.
My dad would come in and
he'd say very declaratively,
"Boys," 'cause I had two older brothers.
He'd go, "Boys," we'd all go, "Ahhh!"
And we'd have to go out and
we'd have to catch cows and--
- [Kelly] Oh!
- Ride horses and ride four wheelers
and take them to the sale.
- Now riding a four wheeler is fun man.
(Justin laughs)
That's not a task.
That's fun.
(Kelly laughs)
And not when you're
working I guess, but you...
Were you ever on a farm?
- No, but I'm thinking--
- [Kelly] Any farm skills?
- Did you ever fall in love with the cows
and not wanna take 'em to town?
- Sometimes, sometimes, but--
- I would Charlotte Web that stuff.
(all laughing)
- I think when you grow
up around it though,
'cause I grew up in front of the...
It's almost a compartmentalization
'cause it's like...
'Cause then my friends that
did do that growing up,
they'd be like,
"Do you like your leather
seats in your car?"
- [Kit] Good call.
- Yeah.
'Cause it's working, it's a living.
- It depends on where you're
from and how you grow up.
But I also would do that.
I'd be like, "why are you do...
I would never be able to do it myself,
but I understand why people do it.
But how did you end up acting,
'cause that's kind of a different...
- Right.
- [Kelly] Did you like drama
in school or something?
- Right.
So in line with the whole
farming situation...
But we would be kind of cutting
hay during the summertimes
and we'd be on a tractor.
Me and my older brothers
would be on a tractor
for like 12 hours at a time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then we'd be
going kind of stir-crazy
in the heat and the bugs and everything,
and then I would have to
create stories in my brain
to entertain myself
and not go kind of have this manic,
weird episode on a tractor.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so I would create
these sci-fi epics,
these really weird period dramas,
and then as I graduated
high school, I was like,
"I think I can do something with this."
And I went to the University of Arkansas
and I got my BA there.
I studied two years as a business major
and then a professor there said that
Juilliard was starting a graduate program
and that I should apply, and
I messed around and got in.
- [Kelly] Gosh, that's amazing!
- [Kit] Huge.
- [Kelly] I love that he saw that in you.
Or the professor she or he,
I didn't know what it was,
but I just mean that's amazing
the professor saw that in you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
Well staying on a tractor for a long time
did not prepare you for being
in the desert for a long time.
Because I did see you post something
that I thought was awesome.
Watch this.
- It is a 105 degrees outside.
I got the air conditioner on
and I'm still hot.
The back of my neck is hot.
I don't even know where that comes from.
Now I'm coming up on a ridge,
if I get over this damn ridge,
best not be no more damn desert.
How the desert this damn big?
- [Kit] Yes!
(all laughing)
(audience applauding)
- So I don't even think I have to ask you
where you're driving,
'cause I've driven from Texas
to California many a times,
and there is a stretch,
is that where you were kinda coming from,
Arkansas to California?
- Yeah.
It was Flagstaff to California.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
There's one thing, if
you don't stop for gas...
- Yeah.
I stopped for...
Well I have a really cool hybrid car,
so I only stopped for gas three times.
- [Kelly] Oh that's awesome.
Yeah.
- But yeah, I stopped
for gas in the desert
and that's after that video.
I was like, "It is so hot out here."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't know what's going on.
I drove from Arkansas,
picked up the car in Arkansas
and I drove from Arkansas to Los Angeles,
and I was driving out here to
do the show, do "Grand Crew."
- Oh my gosh, that's so awesome.
(audience clapping)
That's so very cool.
So did you swear off road
trips from "Road Rules."
Were you just like done?
Were you...
- I like to get neked in
a hot tub (indistinct)
(Kelly laughing)
- [Justin] I saw that.
- Don't worry about it Justin.
- ]Justin] I saw that.
- Do you say "neked?"
- I say "naked."
- [Kit] Oh!
- See I think that sounds more hillbilly.
- If you use it in a sentence,
I came in and he was "neked."
That's kind of country.
If I came in and he was "naked."
Yeah, yeah you're right.
- Exactly!
- You're right.
- You're right,
- We win!
- You right.
(Kit and Kelly laughing)
(audience applauding)
- I was like "That one
sounds more country to me."
You were like, "You know what?
Nevermind."
- [Kit] Nevermind.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] I love that.
Wait, let's talk about your new show
'cause we've had a couple
castmates on here already.
So let's talk about "Grand Crew."
It returns post-Olympics this week,
so tell us about who you are in it.
- Well "Grand Crew" is a
brand new comedy with NBC.
It's a show about a group
of friends in Los Angeles,
and they meet regularly at a wine bar
to wind down as we say,
and they sort of explore
the cultural nuances
of their work life, their love life,
and their friendships with each other.
And I play the character Wyatt,
who is the only married one of the group,
and he brings a sense of optimism
and curiosity to his friends
whenever they find themselves
in weird and awkward situations.
- Yeah.
- And yeah for me, it's been
great to get to explore that.
- And it's funny
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The show is funny.
We need to laugh.
- [Kelly] We need to laugh.
- Wait, what do your brothers do
since you're this established actor?
- Ooh, my oldest brother
is a marketing schemes
manager for Walmart.
- [Kit] Nice.
I Love Walmart.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- And my second older
brother is an engineer
at a nuclear plant.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And a former Marine,
served two tours in Iraq.
- Wow!
- And just had a new baby!
- So here's my question...
Oh that's so sweet!
I love baby smell.
(Kit and Justin laughing)
- So wait, so I just
went there in my head.
So were your parents upset
that not one of you wanted
to do farming? (laughs)
- A little bit.
My father...
(Kit and Kelly laughing)
A little bit--
- He's like, "Seriously, not one of you?"
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I have a ranch and I'm like,
"One of 'em better like it."
It's like...
- I mean I wanna go back and
I could have taken that route,
I could have got my own contract
with a corporation and did farming but--
- Yeah you did what you love though.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Its what I'd do.
- They were kind of
hesitant to support me.
- Yeah.
- I think the day that
I got into Juilliard
I called him...
I got off the plane, I
called him, I was like,
"I got in,"
And he goes, "Oh, that's good.
Well call me if you need any money."
Click!
(audience laughs)
- I mean here's the thing,
if getting into Juilliard
doesn't impress your parents,
there's nothing you can
do that will impress them.
- No.
- My brother had a
really different response
and I can't say it on television.
(Kelly laughing)
- I wanna hear it in the commercial break.
All right, thank you guys so much!
Everybody you can catch
"Grand Crew" Tuesdays on NBC.